not many people have looked at what
we're not really talking about very much
on any level is about teacher well-being
and what kind of mental state teachers
need to be in to teach to the best of
their abilities and what we know is that
if the teacher is in the right place
mentally if they feel good about what
they're doing they're gonna teach better
they will be more creative if they'll be
more motivated they'll be more engaged
it's actually starts off this sort of
positive cycle that if the teacher is in
the right place mentally there's a very
good chance - learners will be - so one
of the things that I'm keen to stress is
that looking after teacher well-being
making teacher well being a priority
understanding teacher psychology
shouldn't be an optional extra shouldn't
be considered some kind of luxury it's
actually fundamental to what it means to
be a good teacher for a lot of teachers
here and they'll be saying hey that's
great but how do I look after myself
there's so many constraints as them
because it's my time there's so many
other things I need to be thinking about
whatever how what can I do to make sure
that I'm looking often myself as a as a
teacher I mean I think one of the first
things that we all have to decide for
ourselves is what our priorities are in
life and this means really taking stock
of what's important to me in terms of
life goal and professional goals so one
of the things that is perhaps
misunderstood and oversimplified is this
idea of work-life balance we have this
idea that there's some kind of fixed
proportion of work and life balance that
we should be aiming for and that's just
not true everybody has to find what
works for them and particularly for
teachers it's not usually that sort of
strict separation of work and
professional life they're very blurred
it means by starting to sort of say what
am i value for what's important to me
where what am I satisfied with looking
at the different areas of my life so my
intellectual well-being my emotional
well-being my spiritual well-being and
my physical well-being and and then
really having to sort of do an audit and
say how how much am i attending to this
and does that match up with my
priorities do I feel comfortable with
that do other places I need to make
adjustments whatever job we're doing we
all find ourselves in the position where
there's way too much to do and not
enough time so I think the first thing
we have to do is we have to sort of
brutally set priorities and we
to learn to say no to things we have to
learn that some things will not get done
but it's making the decisions about what
those things are and saying they have to
go okay about how do you make those
decisions only you can do that mmm could
you give an example of maybe over way in
which you kind of were able to make
those perfect those and I think one of
the things I've learned is that you have
to keep trying to do it you don't get to
a point where I have the perfect
work-life balance now I'm happy with
everything as if I don't need to do
anything I make sure that I take
holidays and I book it off when I'm on
holiday I'm really on holiday that you
really switch off one of the things that
that's coming out of research is this
concept of detachment is really being a
hundred percent in that moment of not
being in work mode I think that the big
thing is making the time when you're not
at work
quality time the other thing and that
also comes from some of the research
we've been doing positive psychology is
really learning to understand what's
within my control and what's not if I
can control it I just let it go and I
feel very strongly that if I can start
to see the positives in everything
that's around you there's a lot of
research that your well-being is
influenced by positive thoughts and
positive well-being so they teach you
for example to do gratitude gratitude
where and I have been doing this for
about a year now and I find it very
helpful is at the end of the day I need
to take a minute you know literally
before I go to sleep I just think of all
the things in the day that I have to be
grateful for and that went well
then well so it's very nice and and I
tell you every day there were so many
nice things that happen and there are
things that you are grateful for
and the more you start to think of it
the more things you become aware of any
such is very easy to take note of so
from what I've understood so far if I
were to make a list okay here's you me
okay yeah I'd say prioritize absolutely
make sure that the time that you have
off work is off work so quality time and
thinking about what you're grateful
about after finding a positive your life
finding the positives in your life
finding the positives in your job and
it's not to deny the negatives and
they're things you'll have to cope and
deal with but it's learning that there's
a lot of positive things and sometimes
we take them for granted
being coming consciously aware of them
can can remind of actually there's a lot
of very good things going on as well
what would be specific to a teacher
maybe I think it applies yeah you're
right I think a lot this applies
generally to people who are working in
all kinds of professions and I think
this this problem with work/life balance
though is perhaps particularly acute for
teachers because there is a very
blurring between work and private life
we're very dedicated it's very much part
of our life and part of our identity so
very often we define ourselves through
our work more so than in some other
professions although other professions
have this as well and so I think
sometimes finding this distinction and
finding how to manage this balance
between these these different areas of
our lives is very difficult and I think
teaching is inherently a stressful job I
think teachers tend to be very other
oriented so they tend to give a lot and
feel guilty for paying attention to
themselves and I think that is also a
problem is that talking about your own
well-being talking about your own needs
talking about looking after yourself and
it's something that sometimes teachers
feel guilty for because they're so other
oriented they're so oriented to helping
their learner's and being there and
while that's always going to be a
priority for us if we start to
understand that if we look after
ourselves first we are better able to be
there for our learners so it's not
selfish at all it's actually just good
practice